hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the very first
chapter of book 3 of them accuses
discourses were treated to an
interesting example that epictetus is
going to use to illustrate some some
broader points about personal appearance
and what genuine beauty consistent and
it's kind of a funny incident this young
man who has spent a lot of time on his
appearance and done so in ways that's
going to get him a little bit of
criticism from Epictetus who who sees us
if you read the chapter sees this as
something he needs to say to the young
guy the young man comes in and epictetus
is going to say why don't you take a
look at what you're doing here and so
you know here's here's the set up to it
he was visited by a young student of
rhetoric whose hair was somewhat too
elaborately dressed and who was a tiger
in general it was high it was highly
embellished and epic few starts by
saying ok let's think about this in
general let's start with dogs and horses
and things that you're familiar with in
that way he says tell me if you do not
think that some dogs are beautiful and
some horses and so every other creature
now one reason this word beautiful well
oftentimes we tend to
with only with a certain kind of
attractiveness the Greek term is come on
actually how those four masculine how
they for feminine and come on
for neuter or or in general and it's a
much broader think of it in terms of
just general attractiveness it also
encompasses the noble the honorable it's
got a very wide semantic range now
Epictetus is is you know questioning
ultimately whether this guy truly is
Carlos whether he really you know as
beautiful and the way that he is going
to do it is going to suggest that
certain societal understandings of
beauty are not really such so we'll come
back to those implications in a bit so
Epictetus gets this guy a tutu with that
let me he's going to give up some
general principles
among these general principles are that
different beings come into being by
nature the Greek word there is actually
the verbal form of Phocis it's a part of
the the perfect pebble cult ah right
they they have arrived it out of nature
they have developed with different
functions or hats
proce I love you know in relation to
different things in the young man says
yes that makes sense horses are not
designed for exactly the same things
dogs are designed for you know moths and
butterflies are designed for something
different these are designed for
something different birds
you know the very varieties of that
falcons are designed for one thing and
robins for another we can go on and on
and on you get the general idea right so
what makes things beautiful then why do
we think that the things that make a
horse beautiful aren't necessarily the
same things that make a dog beautiful
you know if a dog were modeled after a
horse it would be a really strange
looking dog well this has to do is its
function what do we want in a dog again
you know this would be an interesting
thing to compare going to dog shows what
are they actually looking
for in the champions that they they put
forward sometimes it might be rather
bizarre elements to to their appearance
because sometimes are bred I think just
for their appearance but many dogs are
bred for particular purposes so a
greyhound who's whose fan and slow would
not be a good greyhound right because
you want them to be very fast bull
mastiff who was very skinny and was very
fast would not be a very good bull
mastiff because they're bred for what
defending things right Dalmatians
you know interestingly enough what are
donations originally bred for war dogs
they fought with the donations out on
the battlefield that's why they became
such good dogs for firemen not very good
dogs for children as people turned in
the 1990s I think when too many of them
were biting kids so each each thing has
its own particular set of purposes and
what makes it beautiful or ugly is it's
meeting those purposes or failing to
meet that might happen here things are
beautiful to the extent that they obtain
their natural development the Greek for
that is Constantine ultra seen according
to their own nature cross right to
become to become literally the best that
they they could be to be in the best
condition that they could be yeah there
we go
I thought I'd written something wrong so
each kind of thing has some you know not
necessarily final state but at least a
range of states in which it's in its
proper condition right we can say the
same thing about other things as well
like you know objects like times you
know what makes for a good tie well it
should be a certain length like if I try
to wear a tie that's too short for me
it's not going to look good right
because I have a long torso
the tall guy you know maybe the tie
needs to complement the color of the
shirt or pick whatever else you you like
about it
you know it could be too wide too narrow
doesn't tie well at the knots you know
if it's made of the raw material you get
you get where this is going right a
camera what makes for Haiti hollows
camera beautiful camera I'd probably be
functionality you know also the design
is a feel right in the hands you know we
can go on and out of the blackboard has
a certain beauty to it doesn't it which
is why I use a blackboard instead of a
whiteboard we can go on and on about
these sorts of examples so for each
thing it has its own you know sort of
natural principles of development now
how does this work for human beings what
makes a person whether it's a male or a
female or you know whatever we're going
to decide counts as as genders in the
future what makes a person in general
beautiful this is where we get to a
really interesting point it's not their
physical appearance it's not how they
dress it's not what their face looks
like it's not whether they wear makeup
or don't or need to wear makeup or don't
need to wear makeup some other fat fat
is thin it's not any of those sorts of
things what is it then that makes a
person in general beautiful he says
excellence the virtues says what makes a
person beautiful is it not the presence
of a person's excellence very well then
you know if do you do too if you wish to
be beautiful later to achieve this the
excellence that characterizes a person
what is that well observe who they are
who you yourself praise when you praise
people dispassionately when you're not
playing favorites what attributes do you
think a good person an admirable person
an attractive person the kind of person
you want to hang out with it's another
way of thinking about Cabos what sort of
attributes they have and you know the
the suggestions that he has might not
immediately come to mind but they really
do make sense if you think it through do
you want to hang out with the just or
the unjust who who do you praise who do
you like to be with people
are fair people who you can count on
when they've made a promise to follow
through on that or people who go back on
their promises and play favorites and
who you can't really trust the just
justice is something that goes into the
beauty of a human being as a human being
what else the temperate or the dissolute
now you know if we come from a two-party
environment
wherever like yeah I got a drink as much
as we possibly can score as much action
with whatever sex you want and that
makes you a cool person we're gonna have
a hard time understanding what he means
by temperance all you got to do it a
little while with people and you know
circumstances where those sorts of
things have consequences and you start
to get tired of the people who are party
animals and start to say I can't like
this guy over here who has it together
who can help you know who can go out for
a night of drinking and not require us
to stay up until part-time or who isn't
going to sleep with my spouse or who
isn't going to wreck the car and then
you know walk away from it well that
would be justice more than temperance
although you know intemperance could
lead to that so this is another
character trait and that he goes on you
know the the salt controls are the
uncontrolled so in making yourself this
kind of person we could say you know
what about the courageous what about the
prudent in making yourself that kind of
person you are doing way more to improve
your beauty then you can buy anything
that you put into your physical
appearance in some respects it's harder
to it takes more effort to work on being
a just person a courageous person the
prudent person assault controlled person
courageous person than it does to go to
the gym or to diet or to you know go and
get you know work done yes it's sane
right or any of these other sorts of
things
walk around the work
learn how to walk nicely or put some
marbles in your mouth for elocution
lessons what really makes us beautiful
according to have a kid that potatoes
what makes us more attractive is what
goes into us as a human being and that
applies to men just as much as it
applies to women it's not as if courage
is something radically different in one
gender or another or wisdom or
temperance or any of these sorts of
things so that is a general thing that
we want to take forward from it if we're
talking about our physical appearance
though and that's where he's painted
right so this young man sexual
difference according to epictetus tells
us how we ought to look and he's not
saying that every single man needs to be
some big burly type and every single
woman needs to be some you know lift
little thing but he's saying that there
is some physical difference observable
between the two sexes or the two genders
however we're going to talk about it I
don't want to get into a big thing about
that beauty is going to be on the basis
for happiness on realizing what it is
that you've been given so you know for
somebody like me for example this is
about as much beard as it's going to be
in part because it doesn't grow up here
right so I wasn't gifted in that way I'm
not going to grow sideburns
well you know epictetus would be proud
of me for at least having the goatee
because it's important for a man to have
facial hair traffic to use a lot of this
is in a certain sense societally found
right but he's saying look nature has
given you this this is what you ought to
have if a woman on the other hand has a
big bushy beard things look a little odd
right so he wouldn't be you know and
this isn't an issue for us but he
wouldn't be in favor of women going out
and getting fake mustaches and wearing
them all over the place or big beards
you know what you could do in a costume
shop and he's saying beautify the person
that you actually have been down with
you didn't choose
which gender you were given so you know
if your if your horn man
then you should beautify the man that
you are if you're you know a woman that
you should beautify the woman that you
are and you know yeah we could go into
all sorts of discussions about gender
and sexuality and how that fits into
here this is that big penises people
that he's articulating and so he tells
this young man you don't need to be
spending so much time on your bodily you
know your bodily attentions you could
say your new things that you're focusing
on like pulling out your hairs you you
actually should have hair you should
have hairy legs and you know the area
your arms because that's the way your
main focus more on these virtues right
but on the physical thing it's enough
that you take a bath once in a while and
comb your hair and you know look
presentable that's as far as it needs to
go so you know what would ever teeta's
think about you know what's been
happening over the last you know 20
years with the proliferation of all
sorts of creams and lotions and
treatments and all that sort of stuff
that that men get now just as much as
women epic you this would actually be
against it and say that's kind of a
waste of time and you're taking your
good nature and you're you're throwing
it away trying to be something that
you're really not suited for being you
know your if you're a greyhound you're a
greyhound if you're masked if you're a
mastiff be the best mastiff that you can
be be the best greyhound that you can be
he's not saying don't take any care
about physical appearance you know but
he's saying do what actually fits you
know the kind of person that you are so
he'll he'll go on and here we go the
other thing that he says too is don't
worry so much about what what is in
demand among society so he says you know
are you a man or a woman a man very well
than adorn a man and not a woman right
then the guy who responds
says who do you wish to please frail
women kind please them as a man and then
the guy says yes they like smooth men
they like guys who have you know come on
to the sauna
hurry back onto the side of the good
they've gone and guy who I acts or stuff
like that and that mckenas says forget
that there you know who cares what they
like you don't need to appeal to that he
says is this your business and life is
this what you were born for that some
some you know licentiousness all we make
a man like you a citizen of Corinth and
perhaps a warden of the city one of what
about when you're married are you still
going to pluck out your hairs for whom
and for what end
and when you've begotten boys are you
gonna introduce them to the body of
citizens as plucked creatures to know
this is this is kind of silly stuff we
might say the same thing about many of
these other things that we do in terms
of style and beauty like tanning for
example just tanning really serves a
purpose not really a lot of cosmetics
Epictetus would probably say would go by
the wayside many of our treatments that
we do the ones that actually improve
health and thereby improve vigor and
appearance he probably say that sounds
great
but a lot of the stuff that we do that's
purely cosmetic then we call aesthetic
he would say that doesn't he have much
to do with genuine beauty so these are
his views on personal appearance and
beauty they go far beyond the particular
instance of the unfortunate man who
comes to him and gets a little bit of
gentle ribbing by hepatitis and they
tell us what what the stoic thinks about
what makes a person genuinely beautiful